2012 2017 2019
c'est la troisième fois qu andré
perreault voit son entreprise placée en
redressement judiciaire le même scénario
et les mêmes angoisses bas j'ai
l'impression que tout le monde nous
lâche à chaque fois poinot c'est très
très difficile chez troisième donc voilà
on aimerait bien que quelqu'un le
reprenne si c'est possible et puis qu'on
essaye d'avancer un peu plus soit parce
que là c'est vraiment le moral à zéro
pour tout le monde en septembre 2010
sept après le rachat de france et hall
par le groupe n'abuse un fonds
d'investissement néerlandais les
salariés pensaient avoir vu le bout du
tunnel
aujourd'hui ils se sentent abandonnés
par ce repreneur
le pire dans tout ça c'est que il prend
pas décision ils veulent pas investir
dans l'entreprise pour qu'on continue
retrait notre travail
il veut pas dire clairement qui veut
nous se débarrasser de nous donc on est
là dans l'attentes total d'une décision
d'un bus mais dans ce temps là bas le
temps il avance et plus le temps avance
plus non pertes de possibilité d'être
repris ou de trouver une autre solution
cette fois français elle n'a pas pu
financer son fonds de roulement pour une
grosse commande c'est ce qui a précipité
le dépôt de bilan fin janvier depuis son
client s'est déclaré lui aussi en
cessation de paiement est l'unique
fabricant français de ma des aliens ne
trouve personne pour l'aider à sortir de
cette mauvaise passe
un paradoxe il a effectivement depuis
quelques années et c'est très bien une
vraie volonté de développer les énergies
renouvelables éolien en particulier par
contre au plan industriel il n'ya aucune
structure qui existe on est confrontés
aujourd'hui à une forte concurrence
essentiellement au niveau européen
contre laquelle malheureusement on n'est
pas armé pour lutter français elle a
déjà fourni les mâts de 13 des 38 parcs
éoliens au fonctionnement ou en
construction dans la région
sa dernière commande bloqué doit équiper
un parc dans l'yonne